en el vídeo pasado cuando estábamos
generalizando la función del consumo
lineal hice la siguiente suposición dije
que este término de aquí que el impuesto
total o bien el impuesto agregado era
constante todo esto de aquí era
constante lo juntábamos en un mismo
numerito y nos quedaba la orden dada al
origen verdad la intersección con el eje
sin embargo en youtube me hicieron una
pregunta muy muy interesante me
preguntaron lo siguiente que no se
supone que los impuestos totales del
impuesto agregado debería de ser una
función del ingreso agregado en casi
todas las economías las personas pagan
un porcentaje de su ingreso y en general
pues el impuesto debería de crecer
conforme crece el ingreso agregado
conforme crece el pib entonces tiene
sentido hacer esto constante bueno la
respuesta sencilla es que depende de qué
tan cuidadoso quiere ser con tu modelo
en algunos casos puedes decir bueno
vamos a suponer que estoy aquí es
constante para entender más un aspecto
del modelo y eso va a suceder en algunos
cursos y en algunos libros sin embargo
también puedes hacerlo de la otra forma
puede ser un poco más realista y decir
sabes que los impuestos si dependen del
ingreso agregado por ejemplo es decir
que te en mayúscula es igual a una
cierta tasa
una taza de minúscula multiplicado por
el ingreso agregado este es una tasa de
impuestos entonces no sé esta tasa de
impuestos en méxico estaría cerca como
de 30 por ciento verdad un 30% del
ingreso agregado o lo que sea pero sería
un factor multiplicado en tonces si lo
haces de esta forma y pones a quilate
entonces vas a obtener una expresión del
consumo en términos del ingreso agregado
que si considera esto de que pues los
impuestos que el ingreso que el impuesto
agregado es una función del ingreso
brega pero bueno para hacer esto vamos a
escribir esta expresión entonces el
consumo es igual a el consumo agregado
es igual a la propensión marginal al
consumo se 1 x que el ingreso agregado y
más este consumo autónomo verdad + 0 lo
que se tiene que consumir y luego menos
menos otra vez aparece la propensión
marginal al consumo pero ahora en vez de
poner estate mayúscula entonces poner
esta expresión de aquí voy a poner la
tasa de impuestos por el ingreso
agregado vale entonces este por
mayúscula entonces este minúscula x en
mayúscula ok entonces simplemente tome
estate y la sustituido por la tasa de
impuestos multiplicado por el ingreso
agregado ok hasta ahorita no ha cambiado
nada ya pusimos esto en términos de
ingreso agregado vamos a juntar términos
vale vamos a juntar estos dos porque
tienen ingreso agregado entonces vamos a
combinar este término de aquí con este
término de acá bueno entonces idea y
factor izamos un que sería bueno
factorizar 11 1 y creo que si verdad no
sabes que primero déjame poner los
adyacentes nos vamos a combinarlos
entonces se es igual a entonces nos
quedaría ce 1 x ye mayúscula
mayúscula la propensión marginal al
consumo por el ingreso agregado menos la
propensión marginal al consumo por la
tasa de impuestos por el ingreso
agregado verdad todo esto de aquí
entonces es t minúscula verdad no t
mayúscula ya lo estamos sustituyendo por
t minúscula multiplicado por el ingreso
agregado por g mayúscula son esos dos
términos falta del consumo autónomo
verdad entonces al final ponemos más c 0
ok ahora si de aquí vamos a factorizar
un factor común entonces un c uno puede
salir déjame ponerlo aquí abajo bueno lo
voy a escribir verdad lo escribo y
ahorita lo verificamos entonces el
consumo es igual a es igual a lo voy a
poner así como
1 x 1
t
x mayúscula a ésta podemos multiplicar
esto para verificar mira el primer
término el primer término sería c 1 x 1
porque es este de acá y luego este 1 por
menos t porque es este de acá bueno es
eso y luego nos falta sumar nuestro
consumo autónomo más 60 muy bien eso de
aquí tiene muchísimo sentido verdad al
escribirlo de esta forma mira podemos
reflexionar que es este término de aquí
que es este término que es uno éste
porque puedes saber si la tasa de
impuestos fuera de 30 por ciento 13 70
por ciento multiplicado por el ingreso
es básicamente lo que se va a los
bolsillos de las personas después de
pagar impuestos o sea es básicamente el
ingreso disponible
eso disponible ok es esta expresión digo
ahorita le vamos a poner un nombre a
esta expresión de aquí para que sea una
variable por sí misma y vamos a graficar
la en términos de eso pero antes de
introducir otras variables déjame
graficar esta expresión en términos de
che mayúscula del ingreso agregado
entonces quedaría algo así verdad
aquí tendríamos los ejes y ahora como
tenemos los impuestos expresados en
términos del ingreso agregado la
intersección que es el eje c la
intersección con el eje c ahora sería 0
es lo único que es constante c 0 y la
pendiente sería este término de acá
entonces deja lo pongo así lo pondría
que la pendiente la pendiente es igual a
c 1 x 1 - t muy bien aquí abajo tenemos
ya mayúscula verdad que es el ingreso
agregado bueno otra opción es que
podríamos poner una segunda variable
déjame llamarle ingresos disponibles le
voy a poner g20 y que esta variable sea
igual a 1 de x entonces ahora vamos a
reescribir esto va vamos a cambiar este
cachito de acá y que tendríamos
tendríamos que el consumo agregado sería
igual a
la propensión marginal al consumo
multiplicado ahora por el por el ingreso
disponible llegue y luego hay que sumar
esto de aquí el consumo autónomo
entonces tendríamos que sumar ce 0 ok
pensémoslo así eso nos regresa a lo
primero que dijimos verdad en el primer
vídeo en el primer vídeo contemplamos
una situación en el que había un consumo
base y luego una propensión marginal al
consumo multiplicada por el ingreso
disponible pero bueno vamos a graficar
los que lo graficar amos así en función
de el ingreso disponible se vería algo
así aquí tenemos el consumo acá tenemos
el ingreso disponible ingreso disponible
que es lo mismo que uno esté x ye
mayúscula y ahora aquí todavía tenemos
de cero verdad de ordenar el origen pero
nuestra pendiente ahora sería c1 la
gráfica se vería así se 1 dependiente o
sea la propensión marginal al consumo
bueno todas estas de acá son funciones
de consumo totalmente válidas y quiero
agradecerle al comentarista de youtube
por hacerme notar que tenía que platicar
de esto en realidad yo no me había
puesto a pensar
cosas así como él o como ella volviera
que los impuestos dependían de los
ingresos de la persona y en realidad
muchas libras que olvidan que esta
expresión de aquí depende de eso y bueno
es una suposición que hacen pues para
hacer las cosas un poco más fácil y
estás pero bueno incluso si no quieres
hacer estas simplificaciones acabamos de
mostrar que sigue siendo una función
lineal o sea que el consumo agregado
sigue siendo una función lineal del
ingreso agregado